buenos días estamos en la pagina 582 y
vamos a empezar el examen número 4 así
que empecemos con el primer problema y
lo voy a poner por aquí dice cuando la
señora torres entra a la tienda de
abarrotes hay 5 bolsas de pan de medias
noches en el estante tenemos 5 bolsas de
pan para hacer bocadillos una de estas
bolsas contiene 12 medias noches
mientras que las restantes contienen 8
medias noches am creo que eso es
importante de las cinco bolsas la
primera la primera contiene doce panes
doce panecillos o doce medias noches
doce medias noches ok
mientras que las restantes seis cinco
bolsas entonces las restantes son cuatro
las restantes contienen cada una ocho
medias noches ocho medias noches ok dice
si la señora torres compra los cinco
paquetes cuántos bocadillos podrá
ser en total y bueno esto está muy fácil
lo único que hay que hacer es
multiplicar 1 por 12 1 por 12 s 12 ya
esto lo voy a sumar a 4 por 8 cada una
de estas bolsas tiene 8 panes y son 4
por lo tanto 4 por 8 estos 32 y ahora
las voy a sumar para ver cuántos panes
hay en total dos y dos es 4 1 y 3 444
entonces la respuesta es 44 medias
noches o 44 padres lo cual por cierto es
el inciso c así que ya está el primer
problema ya lo tenemos aquí y voy a
resolver aquí el problema número 2 pero
para esto déjame cambiar de color
problema número 2 y dice abc son los
puntos de una recta numérica en ese
orden
déjame hacer la venta numérica por aquí
tengo una recta numérica y por aquí
tengo a déjame cambio de color
por aquí tengo
por acá tengo
y por cierto por acá tengo hacer muy
bien y me dicen si a b es igual a 30 si
ave esta distancia de aquí es igual a 30
y por otra parte si veces 20 unidades
más que ave a si a veces 30 veces pues
son 20 unidades más que 30 es decir son
50 unidades lo que me preguntan es
cuánto vale hace y bueno pues la
distancia de aquí hasta acá pues es la
suma de estas dos es decir 30 50 lo cual
es 80 80 la parte más difícil de esto
fue sumar estos dos y la respuesta es el
inciso d por lo tanto la respuesta del
problema número dos es el inciso d vamos
a hacer el problema número 13 para esto
déjenme borrar esta pantalla y voy a
hacer aquí el problema número 3 el
problema número 3 que me dice x más 3 x
más
esto es lo mismo que a mí me preguntan
cuánto vale
no voy a poner aquí cuánto vale 2 x 2 x
+ 6 yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto
vale esto en términos de a am y bueno
esto también está muy fácil porque esto
de aquí 2 x + 6 si tú te das cuenta que
esto lo podemos visualizar como 2 que
multiplica a x + 3
entonces ya encontramos la solución 2 x
x 2 x 2 x 3 6 pero x 3 es lo mismo que a
este es el dato que me dan por lo tanto
esto me quedaría 2 x a que es 2a y por
cierto este es el inciso c muy bien nos
tardamos como 5 segundos si te das
cuenta de ésta trampita que hice de
factorizar este 2 ahora bien si no te
das cuenta de que dos x 6 es exactamente
lo mismo que 2 x x + 3 entonces aquí
podríamos despejar
y también hay otra forma de resolverlo
decir que x es lo mismo que a menos 3 y
lo único que hice fue pasar este 3 del
otro lado o dicho de otra manera restar
3 de ambos lados de la ecuación y
entonces quien es 2 x + 6
bueno pues sería 2 x x pero x vale menos
32 por al menos 3 + 6 y cuando es esto
bueno pues esto es lo mismo que 2
- 66 es decir multiplique este por este
y este por este distribuye el 2 y
después menos 6 y 6 se van y entonces me
queda que esto es simple y sencillamente
2a llegue al mismo resultado la única
diferencia es que me tardé como 10
segundos más
pero bueno realmente 10 segundos en el
examen de lezea te pueden ser muy
importantes pero las dos respuestas son
correctas y no te llevan mucho tiempo
así que mejor vamos al siguiente
problema el problema número 4 y voy a
borrar esto de aquí y vamos a hacer aquí
el problema número 4 que por cierto
tiene una gráfica la gráfica siguiente
déjeme hacerle una vez tengo por aquí mi
eje de las 10 por aquí me quedé ahí es
por acá mi eje de las x por la camiseta
es x vamos a poner que este es el eje
este de aquí es el eje x y tengo algunos
puntos déjame ponerte dos por acá tengo
un punto por acá un punto por acá que es
el punto
después tengo un punto por acá que es el
punto b y por cierto b está justo abajo
de am muy bien después tengo un punto al
lado de am como por acá que es el punto
c después sube un poco y por acá tengo
al punto de y abajo del punto d pero por
dónde estaba es decir justo aquí está el
punto e y luego tengo algo de escala
tengo que esté aquí donde estaba y es el
valor de 60 después tengo que por acá
arriba a donde está d es el valor de 80
y aquí tengo una pequeña línea y por
otra parte tengo aquí en dónde está ahí
ve que este es el valor de 40 después
aquí en dónde está si tengo el valor de
60 por aquí tengo una línea y después
dónde está de ie aquí es el valor de 80
y por acá tengo otra pequeña línea
además me dicen que este eje representa
a bueno estamos hablando de pruebas de
puntuación de estudiantes aún supongo
que alguna prueba física qué sé yo lo
que sé es que está el eje x representa
la puntuación en la primera prueba el
eje x habla de la primera prueba prueba
ok
mientras que el eje por su parte habla
de la segunda prueba es la puntuación
que sacan en la primera prueba es la
puntuación que sacan en la segunda la
segunda prueba
ok ya tengo un mi primera prueba y entre
una segunda prueba ya tengo mi gráfica
que me preguntan ahora me dice si esta
gráfica representa la prueba de
puntuación de cinco estudiantes cuál de
los siguientes estudiantes tiene el
mayor cambio en su puntuación de la
prueba 1 a la prueba 2 nos vamos a fijar
en la prueba 1 nos vamos a fijar en la
prueba 2 y vamos a ver cuánto cambio su
puntuación así que pues vamos a hacerlo
fijémonos primero en el estudiante
llamado y en el estudiante a cuánto
cambió su puntuación bueno pues en la
primera prueba en la primera prueba saco
40 puntos está justo aquí el estudiante
y en la primera prueba hizo 40 puntos
mientras que la segunda prueba y son a
la mitad de entre 80 y 60 es decir x 70
en la segunda prueba saco 70 puntos y la
diferencia de 70 a 40 de la segunda
prueba la primera prueba son 30 es decir
que aumentó 30 puntos de la primera
prueba a la segunda prueba
estudiante muy bien bien por él de hecho
muy bien que dice el estudiante número
ven bueno el estudiante número ve en un
principio hizo 40 puntos está aquí y
después hizo 60 puntos es decir que el
cambio que hay de 60 40 son 20 puntos 20
puntos bien hasta aquí
ahora vamos a ver qué es lo que pasa con
el estudiantes en el estudiante 0 en la
primera prueba hizo 60 puntos guau pero
en la segunda prueba y son 70 puntos por
lo tanto de 70 a 60 y hay un cambio de
10 el estudiante número se mejoró en 10
puntos de la primera prueba a la segunda
prueba y el estudiante número de el
estudiante número de en un principio
hizo 80 puntos y en la segunda prueba
hizo 80 puntos es decir que el
estudiante de quedó tablas hizo los
mismos puntos tanto en la primera prueba
como la segunda prueba el no cambio y
estamos buscando el mayor cambio textos
pero me falta el inciso e el inciso en
el estudiante en empezó en 80 puntos y
después hizo 60
puntos este estudiante empeoró es decir
que realmente de la prueba 1 a la prueba
2 y son menos 20 puntos bajo su puntaje
menos 20 puntos y entonces lo que estoy
buscando es cuál es el mayor cambio en
los puntajes de estos cinco estudiantes
y bueno el que hizo el cambio de puntos
más grande de la prueba 1 a la prueba 2
es el estudiante a es el estudiante
porque hizo 30 puntos de cambio es el
que hizo más puntos de diferencia
mientras que los demás silo en 2010 éste
se quedó igual y éste hasta le fue peor
muy bien bueno esto es para el problema
número 4 y el problema 5 curiosamente
utiliza también esta misma tabla de
hecho lo que me pregunta el problema
número 5 es lo siguiente
lo voy a poner aquí problema número 5
dice cuál es el promedio es decir la
media aritmética del puntaje de los
cinco estudiantes en la segunda prueba
en la segunda prueba es decir en el eje
y yo lo que quiero es saber el promedio
del puntaje de estos cinco estudiantes
así que vamos a ver el estudiante am
saco 70 entonces 70 más el estudiante me
sacó 60 más 60 más él se sacó 70 otra
vez más 70 más el de saco 80 más 80 más
el que sacó 60 más 60 y a todo esto lo
tengo que decidir entre el número de
estudiantes que es 1 2 3 4 5 todo esto
entre 5 y cuantos esto bueno pues vamos
a hacer la suma 72 veces 60 dos veces y
80 60 más 60 es 120 más 80 es 200 200
más 140 es 340 340 entre 5 y cuántos
esto bueno 6 por 5 es 30 me queda 60
después tengo aquí un 40 a 68 68 es el
promedio del puntaje realizado por estos
cinco estudiantes en la segunda prueba
que por cierto este es el inciso ser así
que ya está tengo aquí el problema
número 5 y vamos a ahorrar este pesar
van para hacer el problema número 6 el
problema número 6 y por cierto por aquí
está siendo mucho frío y me estoy
congelando tengo la mano en tu vida del
frío que está haciendo pero bueno
regresemos al problema número 6 y el
problema número 6 tienen una recta
numérica parecida a ésta que voy a
dibujar como por aquí y después por acá
tengo mi renta numérica y tengo del
menos 2 al 2 antes de ponerlo por aquí
tengo aquí al menos 2 por acá al menos 1
al ser un por acá al uno y por acá al 2
perfecto y después tengo un montón de
puntos así que déjame dibujarlos
tengo por ejemplo en este punto de aquí
este este stem después del -1 al 0 tengo
tres puntos
tengo un wv
y w por aquí
y w y después por aquí entre el 0 y el 1
tengo x por aquí está x después del 1 al
2 tengo los últimos 2 aquí tengo ayer y
por acá tengo hace está muy bien y
entonces lo que me dice el problema es
lo siguiente
en la recta numérica tenemos los puntos
de un v w x y y ceta y son coordenadas
de los correspondientes puntos indicados
en esta recta ok estos de aquí cuando
los siguientes incisos es cercano al
valor absoluto de yo lo que quiero saber
es cuántos el valor absoluto de u
de uno ve bien y si te das cuenta este
es un problema de aproximación más o
menos nos tenemos que fijar a darle
algún valor llave para ver cuál es su
valor absoluto así que vamos a suponer
que uno es aproximadamente
aproximadamente
está entre cero y menos uno y muy pegado
a menos uno voy a decir que es
aproximadamente menos tres cuartos -
tres cuartos creo que es un buen valor
para uno y por otra parte voy a decir
que pep es aproximadamente está como a
la mitad de entre menos uno y cero es
decir menos un medio ok si valiera menos
tres cuartos y b valiera menos un medio
entonces en este caso cuánto va a valer
el valor absoluto de uno más b bueno
pues esto es lo mismo que el valor
absoluto de menos tres cuartos menos un
medio y esto en valor absoluto a cuánto
es igual
bueno pues sacamos el mínimo común
múltiplo el mínimo común múltiplo 44
entre 4 es una por 3 es
en los tres y después dos cada vez dos
veces el cuatro por una es menos dos
menos dos y entonces esto me va a quedar
el valor absoluto de menos cinco cuartos
y bueno cuando aplicó el valor absoluto
es lo mismo que cinco cuartos cinco
cuartos porque recuerda que el valor
absoluto toma un número negativo y me da
un número positivo muy bien y si te das
cuenta cinco cuartos es muy cercano 15
cuartos es lo mismo que un entero un
cuarto es decir estamos muy cercanos a
uno casi pegados a uno y por lo tanto mi
respuesta correcta es 100 porque es el
que está al lado de 1 y entonces mi
respuesta correcta sería el inciso de el
inciso de que me dice
y perfecto aquí tengo el problema número
6 y nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo